madame paule bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous merci beaucoup beaucoup de photos
même paul vous n'êtes pas beaucoup
sortis de votre circonscription de
toronto c'est d'ailleurs là qu'on vous
joint ce soir vous pensez pas que c'est
un peu risqué quand même comme stratégie
pour une chef d'un parti national de ne
pas faire de tournée nationale justement
en fait je n'ai pas dit que je ne ferais
pas tourné juste que je vais passer le
majorité de mon temps d'omar
circonscription malheureusement avec à
la pandémie et les vagues j'ai pas
vraiment eu l'opportunité de passer
beaucoup de temps avec les résidents et
au final c'est eux qui a choisi qui va
leur être présentées mais je soutiens
quand même à nos candidats et candidates
et on a une âme on a nous avons déjà des
manières de leurs soutenir avec les
réunions virtuelles et des autres
technologies plus écologique à et plus
pratique aussi donc pour vous
l'importance et vous faire élire dans
votre circonscription d'abord c'est ça
pas du tout c'est important à chaque
fois qu'il ya une élection générale
c'est très important d'élire les verts
parce que on sait que les verts sont d
excellents député a pour les résidents
de leur circonscription
on sait aussi qu'ils ont ils sont déjà
des voix efficace à pour l'environnement
le climat et à les autres politiques
progressistes ou alors le but toujours
dans une action c'est de lire des verts
partout au canada mais comment allez
vous convainquez canadiens de se rallier
derrière vous quand vos propres troupes
ont du mal à se rallier à vous je
n'arrivais pas à les rallier ya eu
beaucoup de contestations dans votre
parti comment ça se fait que c'est si
difficile pour vous de prendre les rênes
de ce parti là même perdu une députée là
qu'est parti chez les libéraux j'ai lu
et entendu les autres entrevues et
c'était non c'est une question que vous
avez posé les autres aussi à dans une
démocratie et surtout dans les parties
avec beaucoup de militants a il y a
beaucoup de points de vue il ya beaucoup
de passion à ses quelque chose à qu'on
devrait encourager à mais concept
important surtout dans les élections
ah ça nous sommes un parti qui a nazi
pas à s'unifier a alors oui en ce moment
nous sommes ciblées sur ces élections
oui mais vous dites que ça va bien mais
on a tenté de vous et 20 c on a remis en
question votre leadership on a même
tenté de vous priver de financement
madame paule pour faire campagne dans
votre circonscription
ils sont pas quand même des choses aux
partis vers la
gauche comme j'ai dit en ce moment je
crois que l'énergie à de nos membres de
nos bénévoles à 2 les personnes le plus
impliqué a le plus à passionner pour
notre parti c'est dans ces élections ah
on sait que nos chaque parti ont eu leur
histoire de nous des personnes qui ont
traversé pour notre parti a accepté mais
a concédé importants allaient berson là
les uns pour les autres oui peut-être
que des bises de la bisbille dans tous
les partis mais dans le vôtre en ce
moment c'est quand même assez gros ce
qui se passe
en ce moment je vois que des preuves que
les vols allers vers travaille fort pour
à élire des verts à je ne vois pas ce
nouveau décrit là en ce moment à me dire
notre notre but a le mandat dans notre
constitution c'est toujours délicat des
verts dans les élections générales à on
a besoin des verts au parlement parce
que tout le monde sait qui travaille
fort pour leurs atouts circonscription
et aussi pour les enjeux qui a sont
importants aux canadiens canadiennes
tous les verts qui ont été élus à haut
niveau provinciaux et aussi au niveau à
fédéral ont toujours été a été réélu
alors on en a la preuve qu'il travaille
très fort pour les gens au canada
alors monopole à quoi bon un parti vert
alors que tous les partis politiques
maintenant ont des programmes assez
détaillé assez développé un jeu d'abord
nous sommes un parti qui cherche
voies de collaboration et coopération
alors je suis toujours de commencer avec
dire de quoi nous avons une opposition
avec les autres nous sommes partis à qui
propose à mais surtout en ce moment ce
qui concerne le climat nous sommes le
seul parti qui a propose un plan
crédible plan qui respecte le sillon
c'est un plan qui va à deux côtés et
réduire nos gaz à effet de serre mais 2e
et aussi de l'autre côté créé à une à
venir à verte avec une économie
compétitive
malheureusement tous les autres partis
comme les spectateurs ont entendu ce
soir il soutient les hauts lieux d'où
qu'il soutient les aléas projets
d'exploration de gaz et pétroliers et
soutien à la
fracturation hydraulique amis
soutiennent des choses housse est
absolument impossible de continuer avec
ces projets et d'avoir à l'espérance de
atteindre nos cibles de réduire magasin
de sa possible c'est 60% en 2030 est-ce
bien réaliste compte tenu des défis que
ça représente absolument absolument on
voit que tous nos partenaires
internationales sont en train de à
2,2 à mettre en oeuvre mettre en marche
à des cibles très ambitieux on a 27 pays
dont l'union européen qui ont déjà à
s'accorder sur une cible à beaucoup plus
ambitieux que le nôtre arona le royaume
uni avec leurs 60 à 18% on a même les
états unis attaquent leur 50 à 52 %
alors en ce moment assez le canada ah
bon c'est le gouvernement ancien qui est
en train de traîner à et qui
malheureusement ne propose pas une un
plan ambitieux et en ligne avec les
autres grands pays et grandes économies
allaient vers à sont en train de le
faire mais la fin de l'exploitation
pétrolière au canada d'ici neuf ans ou
quinze ans de 2030 2035 omonia riz non
on n'avait pas dit ça du tout on avait a
comme toujours on propose à un progrès a
c'est l'airé à vauvert et
robert zéro émission et même à des
émissions négatives mais absolument qui
est tout à fait faisable on parle
surtout de de pivoter vers l'énergie
renouvelable
on sait que même l' agence
internationale l'âme d'énergie il lui
aussi ils ont reconnu que l on doit à
faire faire à
l'utiliser d'utilisation à l'extraction
pétrolière a on veut créer
l'infrastructure qui peut soutenir une
économie verte aussi c'est le moment à
le faire et comme j'ai dit c'est une
c'est une énorme opportunité à nous
sommes le seul des grands économies qui
ne sont pas qu'il n'est pas en train de
saisir l'opportunité à d'une économie
verte
le bloc québécois souhaite un
gouvernement minoritaire on peut penser
que le npd aimerais beaucoup un
gouvernement minoritaire mais un
gouvernement minoritaire même si vous
n'aviez qu'un ou deux députés à la
chambre des communes peut avoir
énormément de pouvoir qu'elle serait
comment l'exercer vous ce pouvoir de
blocage qu'elle mesure pourriez vous
arracher un gouvernement qui serait la
mesure que vous aimeriez arracher au
gouvernement ses sermons déjà je me
demande dans les gens au canada se
demande pourquoi nous sommes dans ces
élections a et c'est fort possible que
ça va retourner encore une gouvernement
minoritaire c'est quelque chose que bon
je je je je je bon jeu j'espère que nous
aurons parce qu'on sait que les
gouvernements minoritaires dans
l'histoire du canada ont créé des
programmes à important a comme notre
système à de santé à nos tracts santé
alors am le parti vert adam chacun
chaque parlement va toujours chercher à
des points en commun de travail que nous
puissions faire avec les autres partis
ah et on va essayer aussi de concentrer
à les autres partis sur un vrai plan
pour l'environnement parce que ce n'est
pas une question partisans à le climat a
besoin d'un plan ambitieux et table à
nous l'avons pas à nous sommes le seul à
le proposer mais on veut travailler à
main aux mains avec les autres partis
l'import bonsoir qui a le meilleur
programme apport vous évidemment verts
qui a le meilleur programme vert à part
vous les libéraux les conservateurs le
npd
être il faut être absolument honnête
avec les gens à au canada a
malheureusement à les autres partis à le
plan a c'est un plan qui ne restera pas
à ce n'est pas possible on sait que ce
n'est pas possible on sait que le panel
intergouvernemental sur le réchauffement
climatique l'a dit à l'autre jour le
secrétaire général de l'onu aussi ce
n'est pas possible de continuer
d'investir dans les projets à pétroliers
et d'imaginer que nous allons atteindre
même les cibles modeste a été votée je
comprends mais comme vous les chances
que vous formiez un gouvernement sont
quand même faible qui hall qui 2 arrive
en deuxième après vous le kavé
évidemment le meilleur programme heures
il n'y a pas de deuxième comptable a de
l'avenir de notre planète il y assez
juste oui oui a pour à l'action en
relation aucune action a pour nom
réduire nos gaz à effet de serre on ne
peut pas continuer à mettre en ligne de
nouveaux projets à deux pipelines ni à
la fracturation hydraulique ni les
subventions pétroliers et d'imaginer que
nous allons atteindre nos cibles
quelques petites questions d'actualité
êtes vous pour ou contre la vaccination
obligatoire des fonctionnaires fédéraux
comme je dis dans mes entrevues a gelé
ce vaccin sont une pas compte une partie
clé à de notre à lutte contre la
pandémie à on veut que tout le monde qui
peut être daksi né soient vaccinés à un
encouragement est toute ma famille est
vaccinée mais on sait très bien et tous
les partis c'est très bien qu'il y a des
il y aura des exceptions des personnes
pour des contres un pion des conditions
médicaux des raisons qui ne peut pas le
faire il y a des et âme des arrangements
raisonnable pour ces gens on va les
créer on doit les créer donc on n'aura
pas obligatoire mais on on encourage le
plus possible ou bien sûr il faut
reconnaître qu'il ya des communautés ici
au canada qui ont été traumatisés par
leur interaction avec le système
sanitaire par exemple il faut
reconnaître qu'il ya des gens qui n'ont
pas la possibilité d'être vacciné parce
que ce n'est pas recommandée par leur
médecin alors à tous et bien sûr oui
alors voilà alors il faut trouver une en
option alternative raisonnable pour à
ces personnes alors il y aura une option
raisonnable d'accord mais dans la
fonction publique est ce que vous êtes
plutôt dans le camp de ceux qui disent
il faut obliger les tous les
fonctionnaires ou jettent dans le camp
qui disent comme chez autour non il faut
éduquer ne faut pas obliger tiens où la
hausse est tellement tellement à
attriste qu'on parle des cons qu'on
parlât de santé des personnes au canada
qu'on parle du nar en jeu aussi à
fondamental à ce n'est pas une question
des cons c'est une question d'assurer
que les gens qui peut être vaccinés à
sont encouragés de le faire et ils le
font à mais aussi d'assurer qu'il y à
une alternative parce qu'on sait très
bien d'accord on doit avoir une
alternative
madame paule merci beaucoup bonnes
feuilles campagne à vous aussi merci
beaucoup à vous on sait à quoi là